Газові труби опускають з монтажного корабля на морське дно.
Так будують Нордстрім у Балтійському морі.
Трубопровід впритул наблизився до Данії, яка поки
не дала дозволу на будівництво у своїх водах.
Нині ми працюємо у територіальних водах Швеції,
прокладаємо труби Північного потоку-2, це
48-дюймова труба з Росії до Німеччини.
Ми рухаємося у напрямку данського кордону.
"Газпром" досі сподівається таки домовитись з Данією.
Монтаж труб в обхід займе і більше часу, і більше грошей.
Але це ще не всі проблеми Росії, яка обіцяла
запустити "Північний потік" до кінця року та
відмовитись від транзиту через Україну.
Проте Москва не встигає добудувати Нордстрім до
завершення чинного договору про транзит газу
і, очевидно, не дуже рада вести з Україною
переговори про новий договір, що має діяти з 1 січня 2020 року.
Тим більше, що минулого тижня за позовом Польщі
суд обмежив обсяги транзиту ОПАЛом
– суходільним продовженням Нордстріму
Чи зробить решення суду Москву поступливішою?
У своїх прогнозах оглядачі вкрай обережні.
Чи призведе це до того, що "Газпром" скаже:
"нам терміново потрібен транзит через Украину" чи навпаки,
"момент, треба спершу порахувати, які будуть
правові наслідки, щоб нівелювати ці наслідки".
Також незрозуміло, наскільки змінилися позиції
у нового українського керівництва.
Проте це не означає, що Газпром не намагається знайти вихід.
Як повідомляють російські ЗМІ, не виключно, що
Брюссель запропонує Москві постачати газ до Європи
з наступного року без укладання нового газового контракту з Києвом.
Україна є членом Європейського енергетичного співтовариства.
А це означає, що оператор української ГТС навіть без контракту
буде зобов’язаний виставляти на аукціон свої транзитні потужності.
"Газпром" зможе їх викупати, і тут питання буде лише в ціні.
Ймовірності відсутності контракту не виключають і українські експерти.
Усе залежить від рівня накалу відносин між країнами.
Якщо він знижуватиметься, то в принципі транзит
продовжується паралельно з переговорами, і,
зрештою, країни приходять до якогось рішення.
Якщо Україна не отримає контракт на транзит газу,
то саме вона у довготривалій перспективі програє
більше всіх, вважають опитані DW експерти.
У Києві наполягають на довготривалому контракті,
який би відповідав європейському законодавству.
Це єдине, що було відомо напередодні тристороніх
переговорів щодо транзиту газу.
Деталі своїх пропозицій Москві, приміром, обсяги
транзиту та його умови, компанія "Нафтогаз" не розголошує.